we're asked what is the prime
factorization of 36 let me get my little
scratch paper out so the prime
factorization of 36 so let's start with
the smallest prime number we know and
that is 2 and think about this to go
into 36 well sure it does 36 is 2 times
18 so we can write that down 36 is 2
times 18 so now we have 36 as a product
of a prime number and 18 is clearly a
composite number it has factors other
than 1 and 18 so let's try to factor
this further so is this divisible by 2
sure 18 is 2 times 9 2 times 9 so now 9
is a composite number that we haven't
fully factored obviously the twos are
both prime 9 is not divisible by 2 but
it is divisible by 3 9 is 3 times 3 so
we can say that 36 36 is equal to 2
times 2 times 3 times 3 this is its
prime factorization all of these numbers
are prime so now let's input that let's
input that into to make sure we got it
right 2 times 2 times 3 times 3 and you
can check yourself if you have the
product of numbers that are all prime
and the product actually is 36 you have
successfully prime factorize the number
let's do a couple more of these what is
the prime factorization of 30 I'll get
my scratch paper out again so we'll do
the same process so 30 well it's
divisible by 2 so we can write that as 2
times 15 15 isn't divisible by 2 but it
is divisible by 3
it's the same thing as 3 times 5 and
both 3 and 5 are prime numbers they're
only divisible by 1 and themselves so
the prime factorization of 30 is 2 times
3 times 5 let's enter that in so it is 2
times 3
times five let's do one more of these
what is the prime factorization of 73
now 73 is interesting it looks whoops 73
I'll get my scratch paper out for this
we could try to factor 73 so you might
try to well this is clearly an odd
number so - is it going to be divisible
into 73 you might try three you would
immediately see well three is divisible
into 72 if you divide into 73 you have a
remainder of 1 4 isn't it divisible well
4 isn't a prime number so we wouldn't
even try 5 is it divisible into 73
doesn't end in a 5 or 0 7 is not
divisible into 73 7 goes into 70 so
you'd have a remainder of 3 11 isn't
divisible into 73 is divisible into 66
or 77 so not 73 so it looks as I test
more and more numbers it doesn't look
like there's any easy thing that divides
into 73 so I'm willing to go with 73
itself is a prime number so this is its
prime factorization you that's the it's
just 73 so let's write that down so the
answer here let's just write 73 and you
don't want to write one time 73 because
1 is not a prime number you just want to
remember 1 is it's only as one factor
itself a prime factor has a prime number
has two factors 1 and itself 2 different
prime factors 1 and itself in itself is
not 1 so we just want to write prime
numbers here 73 is a prime number let's
check our answer and we got it right